let's talk about some nba because this
is really
pissing off a lot of people we got the
story from the black wall street times
access is the new civil right they say
with no mandate some nba players
refusing covet vaccine ahead of season
they say the most popular question that
players have been asked has been
concerning their vaccination status
currently there is no mandate from the
league for the players to be vaccinated
league spokesman mike bass told espn
quote a vaccine mandate for nba players
would need an agreement with the player
association the nba has made these
proposals but the players union has
rejected any vaccination requirement
most nba players are vaccinated but
stragglers remain roughly 90 of nba
players are vaccinated as training camp
approaches according to league sources
but tensions are growing between
staffers who are vaccinated and players
who refuse them
in some instances staffers said they're
up to the players aren't facing the same
vaccine requirements as most team staff
and referees in other instances staffers
that they're concerned about the health
risks of being exposed to unvaccinated
players
two of the league's biggest stars
bradley beal and kyrie irving both said
they were not vaccinated during their
team's media day and i just got to say
guys
you need to stop fighting this
us rich people are exempt from all of
this nba stars famous podcast hosts yo
you go look at the met gala just accept
your fate you know uh aoc doesn't got to
wear a mask all of the serpents do
all right this is this is the direction
that i'm kidding by the way but this i'm
half kidding it's true though like nba
players are like we're not going to do
it meanwhile the support staff are being
forced to do it yeah it's one of the
more interesting stories and uh you know
i don't see any national guard coming in
uh to replace kyrie irving that could
average 25 points in eight assists a
game
um but it's really interesting with the
nba because um it actually first started
off with you know for folks who you know
who don't know like lebron james has
massive power over the league it's
almost like whatever he said kind of
sways and he actually
came out and like didn't want to get the
vac i think he just got vaccinating but
he didn't want to get the vaccine and
that kind of forced the players
association to say you know what no
mandate so it's it's really interesting
to see and especially the the star
players speak out so like a bradley beal
kyrie irving who hold a lot of weight
that's gonna be interesting to see
andrew wiggins who is the uh
um shooting guard for the watch for the
warriors in uh in oakland he applied for
the religious religious exemption and
got got it denied so now he could only
play away games i'm really curious just
to see how that's going to turn out only
away games it's interesting the
difference between the nfl and the nba
right because like in the nba you have
five guys can win you a championship for
the most part i mean you do you do have
a bench but it's five guys with the nfl
you need 12.
so so the the star power is much greater
in the nba one individual like lebron
can command a team in the league yeah
and in the nba they need um like they
need those star players to fill those
seats like in nba's just those star
players are more rare than than the nfl
so it's really interesting to see like
the kyries bradley bill and other other
players come out and uh and speak out
yeah because bradley bill just had a
media day and he said hey you know what
i already had kovit i have the
antibodies he said and then he like
looked at the meeting and said i assume
all you guys have are vaccinated yet you
could still get it so it's like i said
it's interesting right now just with the
mandates and all this stuff and um and
then
i'm curious of what's gonna happen
andrew wiggins because now the owner
might be like you know what if you're
not gonna get vaccinated i can only
abuse you on the road i'm gonna just
release you and then just pick up
another guy who's willing to uh yeah but
he's [ __ ] true right yeah yeah and
he's he's a good player he's not like
he's like a guy you just kind of like i
said no national guard is going to come
in for andrew wiggins
plays on 15 points in 10 boards a game
you know there's a lot of protests there
was a video from a couple days ago where
people in staten island who are
unvaccinated like stormed into a mall
and we're challenging usa and cause new
york has the vax mandate
but you see little pockets here and
there you can google it you can find the
stories of a few hundred people i don't
think it's enough to stop government
overreach you know the government's
gonna mandate people just gonna follow
suit i agree i haven't i haven't i
actually thought that like the turnouts
would be much larger we haven't seen
them now i covered a few of these
anti-mandate protests back in california
and um one thing that i've noticed at
least from the process that i covered is
the first responder community is really
against the mandate i'm talking about
nurses police officers
like i said the story i think to watch
out right now is the l.a county
firefighters are now going to be suing
the county and then they are really
stepping up and saying we're not doing
this so i think um that could be a
turning point for for a lot of first
responders depending how that uh
firefighter case goes i'm not convinced
that's gonna affect the public the way
you know kyrie irving would you got the
nba and what happens if if some owner is
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you
know use you for these games because
you're refusing to get vaccinated and
they can't do it they got star power on
their hands when celebrities like nicki
minaj come out all of a sudden their
fans their fans don't care about your
tribe they don't care about science they
don't care about whatever your rules are
they're just like
big fan nicki minaj she said it we're
done and they'll start tweeting in
support of her love you nikki you're the
best especially
with these nba stars now lebron i guess
came out
you know and it was praising china oh
i'm sorry that was a lot
yeah
he came out and was saying you know that
he i guess he got vaccinated and he's
supportive of it so that will have a lot
of weight
but i got to say you know when i watch
some of these viral videos
i feel like regular people are going to
see this and that those vocal uh
you know people in the nba or of high
status
are gonna for one
probably a lot of people will just
blindly agree with them there's probably
a lot of people who are gonna be like
i'm a big fan dude yeah whatever you say
but there's gonna be a lot of people now
who feel will feel less scared
they're gonna be like if they can do it
so can i i can speak up i can stand up
for myself and it's really interesting
to see uh in in there was there were
protests a big protest in new york
i'm surprised he protested in new york
over this i mean new york is a democrat
stronghold but you see new yorkers
holding up signs i kind of feel like
the media is lying about the sentiment
on this one if the bluest place in the
country new york city i think it's the
bluest place maybe i'm wrong maybe it's
san francisco i don't know but
particularly democrat place has
thousands of protesters certainly
regular people are like yo the vaccines
are great but you can't force people to
to take these things right i've had for
the last i think week when i go into
twitter what's happening first thing
that shows up is biden's vaccine mandate
for workers is supported by legal
precedence experts say and that same
headline and things keeps popping up
every day like they're trying to
convince me of it
so they're obviously it kind of supports
i think it supports what you're saying
that i think that the media is forcing
the narrative yeah attempting to there
it that that is such a manipulative
propaganda thing because you can argue
that the legislature can can put in
rules for osha but not biden by decree
so that's
why why are we getting our legal
analysis from twitter staff you know
what i mean but people believe this
stuff the problem is like when the media
does this thing they are not exactly
able to convince like normal schmucks
who are watching tv to be like oh now
the media said it let's go and get the
vaccine it's more about
like private organizations like
restaurants and like club owners they're
thinking that oh is is this the mass
sentiment now we have to mandate it i
went to brooklyn literally this saturday
and i had to show my back squad in one
club and in order to get into a yacht
so they are mandating it left right and
center and i think like the way the
private organizations get their
information is that they watch media and
they think that oh this is the sentiment
so we need to follow the laws and then
they just like just imply with it well
that's why it's big if the nba stars and
celebrities are coming out and they're
speaking out against this yeah i thought
exactly i thought the nicki minaj was
wild huge wild cycle
just that crossover with with her and
tucker is exactly what we needed i wish
i was dude i wish trump was uh i wish
trump had his twitter because i just
wanted to see what he would even even
say
he would be like nicki minaj one of the
greatest rappers of all time everyone
agrees he's standing up for the rights
of the working class
but i was yeah i love i love that week
because i remember just watching tucker
and he would just he would be like crazy
nick and then he would just bash the
whole gop he would be like why is nicki
braver than any gop representative it's
true you always have like those
republicans like oh but she's you know
pro abortions it's like that that
doesn't matter on right now like right
now we're
this is a this is an area where you
could win over a lot of people when it
comes to this this is body autonomy went
over people in the special hip-hop
community like like if nikki says
something
all right and hip hop is like like you
know 90 black probably like and they
will like roll with it like but you saw
people
exactly pushing back nikki it's like hey
she needs to be like shut down now like
it was huge i think jay-z just had a
meeting with the new mayor of new york
and it was all like oh i'm talking to
her of how we could you mean the
governor yeah the the governor and he
was like oh i was talking to her about
how we could uh you know get more of our
of our people in our community
vaccinated so it's like it's big when
nikki could come out and step out
against that narrative he then i love
that she was speaking about censorship
and then she like blasts those
journalists and like hassan [ __ ] got
real and that was the best day ever like
out of all people no my favorite thing
like the the reason why i was so much on
the nicky train is like if you could
drive joey uh joy reid crazy on msnbc i
am on your team so i love watching you
enjoy this video
hassan's response to nicki was that
tucker was a white nationalist correct
here's a guy who has nothing to say for
this conversation like hassan exactly is
just like if that's if that's his hot
take for this it has nothing to do with
the issues of liberty liberty freedom
medical public health it's just
literally like well that guy's a white
nationalist wow excellent commentary on
the issue of son brilliant yeah and then
we're also seeing with with the college
universities it's like even with the
mandates they're still seeing covet
outbreaks like duke duke university had
like an outbreak of like over 300 uh
kids tested positive for covet and only
eight of those kids were unvaccinated so
even you're you're seeing it in duke
university you're seeing a lot of these
universities where like their
vaccination rate is like at 99 or
you know 98 like i was even reading
harvard just went to like online classes
for three weeks and they're like their
vaccination rate is like at 97 percent
well
let me let me pull this up real quick
cbs news kareem abdul-jabbar says nba
players who refuse the covet vaccine
should be disciplined oh boy oh
disciplined
these people are insane get in line boy
they're they're they're genuinely nuts
yeah stephen a smith too on espn was
coming out and saying oh you need to
trade kyrie irving it's like
that that's that's just the the kind of
world we're living it's like you you
like step out of that narrative and
they they attack you it's like man it's
not even about like i said even the
places that are we're seeing the most
vaccinated rates there's still outbreaks
yeah this is what's concerning me if
that trend continues what you're
pointing out at like the in the colleges
um and that people keep getting these
breakthrough cases after vaccination
then at what point will people say stop
mandating this if it's if there's still
going to be breakouts anyway because
like like they don't mandate flu shots
you know they you can get a flu shot and
it can help you but you can still get
the flu
so at what point are people gonna i have
two questions
they they're they're i'm seeing all over
twitter they're like the unvaccinated
are a threat to the vaccinated right
they're like we got a protective
vaccinated from the unvaccinated which
makes sense a lot of people on the left
are saying like
you know uh if if if we're gonna get
through this and everyone has to be
vaccinated otherwise i'll be variants
and i'm like
like the flu huh like the flu vaccine
that nobody gets like a lot of people
get it the flu shot every year yeah the
copa 19 vaccine is the first vaccine in
the world that doesn't work unless you
have it too well no no i i i'm not
talking about i i understand the point
they're making there'll be variants
right yeah because it'll it'll you know
fester within certain communities and
then eventually can you know
the vaccine stops working but we don't
even do that for the flu so what's
different here like no i get i get covet
is worse i get it's like you know scary
people can't breathe and stuff like that
but we're not talking about airborne
ebola is it just like because it is
novel all of a sudden we're like this is
the one where everyone's gotta get the
vaccine or what
yeah i don't know we're in some
interesting times and then we're also
seeing the put the push for the booster
shot so that like fda just recently came
out and they didn't approve it for
everyone i think they only approve it
for 65 and older it's also also
interesting to see how the other
countries react so the president of
mexico came out and said we are not
vaccinating anyone under 12 years old
we're not letting big pharma play a role
in this which i was like whoa and he's
and he's a leftist uh almost as a
leftist so he came out and spoke out
against it
that's what i'm interesting to see is
there the pfizer is making that push to
get like five and five to
twelve-year-olds vaccinated
which is like just i mean they're we
haven't seen any data that they needed
no risk whatsoever
there's well we won't say no risk but it
is like
very very very limitable yeah and i
guess the issue is they're concerned
kids will get it and then transfer to
old people or so yeah but i gotta say
you've got
the the the there's interestingly two
main camps in this there's
and well actually at this point i don't
think it's anti-vaxx i think it's mostly
anti-mandate i think most people
actually agree this is it's fine get it
but the weird question is like why are
you making literally everyone get it it
doesn't it it doesn't make sense like
why are they forcing everyone to do it
the big thing that they're not telling
you joe biden comes out and he said you
know 98 of people got to be vaccinated
to go back to normal what they're not
telling is that a large portion of those
who aren't vaccinated live in the middle
of nowhere
so it's like you can see an nba player
and ask them like why won't you get the
vaccine and they'll say well i've had it
before i have the antibodies the
government should mandate this but what
they're not showing you when they say
like you know a quarter of people's like
a quarter of people haven't gotten it
it's like yeah you know like
jim bob who lives up on the mountain
yeah who's got no neighbors and is a
homesteader is like not gonna drive into
a city to risk himself during a pandemic
just to get a vaccine that would reduce
the risk he doesn't have because he
lives in the middle of nowhere they
don't take into consideration rural
living homesteaders farms people who
don't go into cities and people who are
talking to their doctors and for medical
reasons aren't getting it they're just
blankets saying everyone's got to get it
you know that makes no sense
why would someone who lives in rural
wyoming be concerned about getting sick
when they don't see anybody for six
months they're probably like i'm not
even going to see a doctor to give me
the vaccine but they include those
people in all these numbers too yeah now
like in california you know l.a county
which is one of one of the bigger
counties in the united states
ellie county is so big that like it's
not just like the city of la there's a
bunch of rural communities in la county
so it for for us it didn't make sense to
see that you know they were like shut
down all these businesses and it
affected even the rural communities um
you know in the middle of nowhere like
you said that they're not connected to
the city you know it's a it's like a
one-size-fits-all
um which has just been gentrimento then
you know l.a county 2 was the only
county out of all of the united states
to make the restaurants um do close out
their indoor and also outdoor dining
they were the only only county that did
take out only as well and it affected
the rural communities that are not even
near the city thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat
and we actually will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you